[Music]
wonder woman
diane i've got some bad news treat me
like
[Music]
you laughing no i don't
[Laughter]
oh my god are you okay
style smile what we got
forgotten who would wear it let's try
something else i'm not even wearing
underwear
that's how comfortable these pants are
really yeah
i think it's going to draw too much
[Music]
attention
[Music]
you truly delight me we just collate
[Music]
[Music]
[Laughter]
[Music]
[Laughter]
[Music]
i love kristen wiig we have this
beautiful friendship
it was an instant connection and we have
a very similar
sense of humor wow you're so
funny no one's made me laugh like this
in such a long time
miguel is a great scene partner and
friend but at the same time we can
immediately go into like those scenes
where we have that sort of
super villain hero rivalry
gal and kristen would make this awesome
duo
that was pretty good it's great to see
that love and friendship blossom
it just filled me with joy gal and i
love each other
she's brilliant
[Music]
i love kristen wiig we have this
beautiful friendship
it was an instant connection and we have
a very similar
sense of humor wow you're so
funny no one's made me laugh like this
in such a long time
miguel is a great scene partner and
friend but at the same time we can
immediately go into like those scenes
where we have that sort of
super villain hero rivalry
gal and kristen would make this awesome
duo
that was pretty good it's great to see
that love and friendship blossom
it just filled me with joy gal and i
love each other
she's brilliant
you